gli ex fidanzato mentre diceva
all'incirca tutte le volte che la sua ex
era che entrava non ci credo ciao
ragazzi bentornati a una nuova puntata
di vita buttata il tema della puntata di
oggi è casi umani prima di partire con
qualsiasi tipo di polemica sappiate che
quando noi diciamo casi umani non
intendiamo un vero caso umano clinico
intende ma semplicemnte è una persona
che magari in un momento si è comportata
in maniera strana ci ha fatto strano
anche perché sono dell'idea che la colpa
non sia mai dell'altra persona anzi più
delle volte la colpa è nostra è una cosa
che volevo dire prima iniziare questo
video casi umani in un modo di dire is
not be all psicologico il problema ok
per fare questa chiacchiera o ospite
all'interno degli studios di casa mia un
amica una persona che ha avuto a che
fare con molti casi umani ha anche
curato una rubrica su instagram sto
parlando di buongiorno graziana
[Musica]
allora senti graziano sei pronta per
questa chiacchierata
parliamo di casi umani io ho qualche
caso umano e sono pure riconciliato con
il mio caso umano il mio di concepimento
con il caso umano sarà una cosa che
diremo la fine del video e faremo anche
informazione in tutto questo ciao ciao
buongiorno graziano il mio caso umano è
questo ragazzo che avevo conosciuto un
po per caso mi aveva invitato caldamente
andarlo a trovare in olanda dove
lavorava un bilancio come un frisbee in
questa situazione perciò insomma voglio
vedere succedere dopo diventa un po
freddo lui confessa e dice che si sente
in colpa perché fidanzato dei dieci anni
lo sapevo segue tutto lo sproloquio
della sua vita sentimentale io li ho
fatto fare di venire qua non la migliore
vacanza
lo sapevo io ne ho beccato uno non ha
fatto niente non ha detto nulla finché a
un certo punto io ho chiamato prima
ancora che ci incontrassimo caso
risposta punti ne avrei parlato questo
ragazzo mi invita ad uscire io presi un
calzino e lui un 0 dopo essere stato
tutta la serata a parlare di palestra
bibitoni mesi che dieta a fine c'era
aria ma la casta della barella guarda
gas inizi a far finta di non trovare il
portafogli giocato operativi faccio
guarda che tu appoggiato sul tavolo
siamo arrivati e progetti allo sci ma
cosa hai fatto gli ho fatto io
volentieri no problem agliana in
macchina e li il portafoglio ricompare
magicamente dalla tasca del suo
pantalone dicendomi eccoti anni 50 euro
e chiami pure il resto ovviamente non
accettati sono nato bloccato proprio
prendi una spranga pam classe 250 euro
gli strappi vada così esagerata ma te ne
prende lenti rifilare sempre vecchi
insieme durante un rapporto arrivati
all'apice del movimento di tipo mi si
avvinghia reso grande dal mio corpo o
modi kraken proprio lì per lì non capivo
quest'anno volesse fare cioè non mi
colapasta cara mi sono staccato con la
forza gli ho chiesto cosa volesse fare
enemy ha rivelato che voleva per un
bambino e che mi seguiva da una non sono
scappato da voi è ritagliato istigatori
a my lai è scappato orleans usa del
polipo ancora lì carattere via di
parlarvi del mio caso ma alla fine il
capo sono andare locali come la buccia
ospita sia io che la mia ragazza siamo
un po due casi umani una volta stavamo
cominciando mentre cominciavamo abbiamo
tipo iniziato a urlare in bocca ha
sentito pazza che si sono trovate le
ragazze si frequentiamo terra di due
mesetti io abbastanza presa lui sembrava
ci vediamo l'ultima volta tutto wow dopo
scompare a rio in faccia viva subito
succede qualcosa lo risponde ora sono
mentalmente instabile e non sono se
quando vi passerà questa quota potrà
essere ancora interessato a te libertà i
tavoli sapere cup successo allora gli
propongo di vederci vai vediamoci
domenica lo chiamo ok va bene ma questa
domenica e io sì e no pensavo nella vita
all ente orali con le mie amiche noi
siamo l'espressione domenica nella
visita come sinonimo di mai domenica
nella vita
questa della rubo sabino grazie a una
seria di un momento importante di questa
chiacchiera che quello nel quale io
chiedo solitamente agli ospiti di darmi
la persona che forse mi supera in casi
umani mia cugina un saluto praticamente
un ragazzo con cui sta uscendo mi chiede
lei avesse per caso delle foto del pene
di suo padre di suo fratello perchè
perchè lui voleva fare un paragone verso
sugli uomini di mia cugina cioè il padre
e il fratello era una questione di
sottomissione di vita che lo giuro è
quella roba mi dici non credo d'aver
capito scusa anche voi di perdere capace
come dire cugina telefonò per smettere
non poteva tipo mangiare il gelato
davanti a lui perché sono si citava
toccargli la spalla che se ci dà una
ragazza molto particolato all'avversario
delle poi papa alla grecia e diana e o
di consumare ne ha incontrato talmente
tanti che potrei perdere il conto
semplicemente perché io sono ma con una
cosa uno si è stati fa molto rara o il
braccio destro molto più secco è fatto
altro che ci sono reti delle persone che
non partono veramente pasiano intere
pareti e due signore molto molto anziani
hanno aiutato a guardarmi malissimo
pignano detto consumi ma quel braccio lo
può tenere
io sono stato eletto e che senso ha
tenere signora no perché insomma con dei
dati di mesto se le assi comi a vivere
nel mondo un decoder sero malfunzionante
questo braccio signora va semplicemente
diverso pensavamo che siccome non ai 18
anni
allora i genitori di costringevano a
tenerlo
io sono basito o la signora veramente
migliora un violante ma veramente
ignorante e non riuscire a capire che
quando thaci sulla costa che ranzani è
meglio con quale audacia tutti avvicina
versione che non ha mai visto in vita
turistici per quanto questo braccio
comunque l'audacia innanzitutto dai un
parere non richiesto una persona cioè si
scherza si ride e tuttora attivare la
seconda sarà si commenta da sola un
amico d'infanzia che le dieci anni fa ha
fatto fuori una mostra con una gomma per
cancellare ammessi il corpo dentro un
frigo giocattolo e ci ha urinato dentro
e anche fatto vedere il tutto i suoi
genitori per fratello schiacciano le
forme di mangiarlo
il fratello prima va dal balcone da
sempre avuti parecchi perché poi mi di
scorza per fortuna però è uno che mi
ricordo è stato una ragazza con cui
parlavo e le pratica si lamentava del
fatto che non rispondesse velocemente
messaggio perché io sono un tipo che non
ama chattare quindi l'ho sempre detto
ogni giorno mi ripeteva che di me non si
fidava eccetera buongiorno mi sveglio la
mattina e guardo gli stati di whatsapp
credo che lei non c'è una foto con altre
ragazze in cui si baciano aderiscono una
scusa invece ci stanno sentendo to me
c'è una foto con un altro è la società
stata e metano ci stiamo sentendo punto
ci sono fiori spa sperduto viene
ricercata eccetera però diciamo che
questa è un caso che chiamo caso la
negazione ci fa una cosa e per l'america
e la maggior parte delle volte in cui
qualcuno ti dice oh ma non è che tu sei
tipo in realtà ne rendo conto anche
quando io critico
sto parlando di me e fammi capire sono
di quelle persone che poi sparisce
quando che i saw the ability prendendo
l'autobus una signora di mezza età con
uno di quei classici vestiti da casa con
motivi floreali marino per pelli molto
centra in mezzo all'autobus
relativamente pieno decise di abbassarsi
le mutande da sotto al vestito
metterselo in mano e poi cercare un
posto libero dove sedersi per
disintegrare il sedile raga fateci
sapere qua sotto nei commenti i vostri
casi umani saranno più prima di andare a
dormire farò qualsiasi cosa io volevo
dire solo che qualcuno è finito un
onesta e scalea ha ammesso io apprezzo
più di tutto perché la grande lezione di
oggi qual è che noi possiamo incontrare
un sacco di casi umani nella nostra vita
ma noi saremo sempre il caso mani di
qualcun altro quando andrete a dormire
guardate allo specchio davanti al vostro
riflesso di te ma che cos'è
io sono il caso umano di quadrante ho
incontrato un tipo che mi ha chiesto se
mi poteva restare l'apparecchio la tipo
gli uccellini che puliscono identico
che schifo calcolate che mi sono aperto
al mondo gli appuntamenti dove tortona
parecchio perché prima mi sentivo
inchiavabile a saperlo prima me lo
teniamo più nei 32 anni sei casi umani
troviamo la mia sta con me solo per far
ingelosire nemici un giorno del mio
compleanno del giorno dopo di tipo
questo mancato poi un anno nasce con lui
viene rilasciata è una roba che nasce
dall insicurezza dalla non accettazione
e ti porta anche a fare ste cazzo alle
quote la porta una persona sofferma il
più persone a soffrire certo
assolutamente su 32 da mettere un
pochino ok perfetta in cui sono stato
quattro anni avevo dei dubbi che mi
stesse tradendo quindi ho guardato il
suo telefono mentre stava guardando ho
trovato il 18 ciò che spiegazioni
mostrandogli il telefono ha preso in
mano cancellate le sot agirà tutte le
prove verso di me e mi ha detto guarda
non c'è niente ha così vengono esiste
non affrontato nemmeno il discorso e tu
sei pazza ma tu sei completamente pazzo
guarda io non ho problemi campanati
possono pasticcere se vuoi un corsa te
lo faccio io siamo la non spesi a te lo
posso raccontarti questo assurdi prego
veramente n
il fratello e un amico privilegiare poco
a danilo ne stanno vedendo una partita
alla televisione forse citofono sale
questo link neanche troppo amico e
chiede subito senza neanche salutare di
andare in bagno
cinque minuti 10 15 minuti 20 minuti 25
minuti in questo esce dopo mezz'ora dal
bagno dove lo sentiamo uscire sentiamo
solamente la porta che si chiude
andiamo a girare questo se n'è andato è
avvenuto è venuta a creare ha usato un
aggettivo che amo molto il mio telefono
da lottare molto volgare valuta con di
reno
kakà si fa a saperlo ho lavorato questa
è una brutta parola a marco e lo sono
gli speaker napoli tel
wow i due se non la nota e latrina
imparando l'italiano o d'ora le mie che
cosa in questo tempo il mio consiglio
hanno allora la mia esperienza è la
seguente ho incontrato un ragazzo se
molti anni fa se lui voleva che io il
suo immaginario ci provassi con altri
che questi ci cascassero e nel momento
in cui capito era lì lì per dire dai
facciamo sono qui pronto tutto caldo vi
devo dire non mi fai schifo la iii via
rossi continua a dirlo e io ho iniziato
letteralmente a fare la seguente cosa ci
sono io al male con il bagnino mi fai
schifo o si continua a dirlo io montagna
con un boscaiolo gli dico fai schifo
così il continuo ancora prigione con un
poliziotto poteva dirmelo
non sapevo più cosa inventarmi stessa
cosa all'infinito del re the seeker
tempo fa ci siamo sentiti in lui mi ha
detto non ho più questo tipo di reti
share che ho scoperto di non essere gay
ma di essere goi scritto g0 sono uomini
attratti da altri uomini
ma che di base non vogliono
un'interazione sessuale è come se fosse
una rosa più mentale sentimentale
emotiva evidentemente questo qui un suo
modo per sfogare questo suo essere un
gol
e la cosa che ho imparato è che spesso
quando tu hai a che fare con una persona
che tu hai reputato stramba a volte
basta semplicemente togliere un attimo
l'astio del momento la stranezza al
momento parlarci e scoprire che in
realtà tutta questa stranezza non c'era
ma molti i problemi sono di
comunicazione a parte quando incontrano
ha meno problemi quota rimarrà un lota
saluta nota grazie a gianmarco la nota
l'unica nota
noi ragazzi siamo arrivati alla fine di
questo video mettete il pollice in su se
avete anche voi avuto a che fare con un
caso umano ma soprattutto fateci sapere
quali sotto quali sono stati iscrivetevi
a questo canale attivate la campanella
logistica per non perdere su un
contenuto cosa in realtà nessuno come
contornano 10 quindi non fatelo te lo
dico bravissimo di palla e ricordi basta
grande semplicità annoiarmi non mi
seguite
ciao
a grazie graziano presa sugli euro di
ora chiusa